Trump is an idiot and everyone around
him and those who work for him or with
him knew it like you look at all these
people whether it's Jared Kushner or
Ivanka Trump or or Bill Barr or any of
the other people who worked as advisors
they all knew
they all knew that all these theories of
uh of trucks full of ballots and and
they were bringing them in at 4 00 am
and there were dead people voting and
reservation like all these things are so
ridiculous again like two to have
widespread voter fraud you would have to
have a very intense strategic Network to
pull that off right and all these people
knew that it was insane and it wasn't
real but Trump kept going on air and
doing his speeches and spreading lies
and doing this and everyone else is like
I I mean is anyone gonna stop him you
know and everyone's like the guy's an
idiot but I'm not gonna say anything
right well the point where Bill Barr has
to explain decimals how decimals work to
him is absolutely unbelievable like no
not 63 point zero zero zero zero six
three percent like you don't even know
how a [ __ ] decimal Works how are we
in a situation where Rudy Giuliani the
drunk person is leading the charge for
him to go out and declare the election
they don't know how decimals work they
don't know that in Detroit yes they do
move ballots in boxes because that's how
it works there it's always
worked there the last election that you
had there they did the same thing with
moving boxes of ballots that's just how
it works like for Bill bar to like do
the tick tock do this thing where he
absolutely destroys Trump but the thing
that most that that bill Barr destroys
here is the big lie he takes big big
huge massive dumps all over the big lie
and all over 2 000 mules and it's
beautiful
um I can't you know I don't I don't know
that these words were ever gonna come
out of my mouth but I can't thank Bill
Barr enough
um for his for his words
honestly yeah I want to bring in uh
David Bender here he's joining us uh
David what did you take away uh your
your mic is muted there what do you take
away from uh some of the testimony that
we've heard so far today well it's uh
not thanking Bill Barr enough is still
Elite for me okay
there's still you know the nose
production uh no collusion part that I
want to work through but that's therapy
uh here's here's some quick takeaways
first of all uh when Liz Cheney came out
and did again what she's going to do I
think now we know in every hearing she's
laying out the case she not an attorney
but playing one on TV she is brilliant
at studying out the legal case which
ultimately is going to be important for
uh maracarlo so what did she set out
today she set out uh something that I
think is going to be a huge takeaway
because we're going to hear about it the
minute someone puts a microphone in
front of Rudy Giuliani uh sir when were
you drunk are you drunk now right how
often are you drunken if you look at the
clips he looked drunk in the clips right
the that the Apparently inebriated Rudy
Giuliani which was her exact quote I
wrote it down it's going to be a major
takeaway here because he's going to push
back at it and it's going to be one of
those fun food fights that that will
play out on Fox News and that is another
big takeaway
because uh uh star well because of his
he was very good as witness very
effective uh the fox analyst uh and what
what happened here was a full frontal
attack by the president and the White
House on Fox news right that's now been
revealed we know that he was ultimately
fired for having told the truth they did
a great job when they were a news
organization so anybody who is going to
be processing the the sort of
contradiction between Fox News only
tells the truth but they were lying here
that doesn't work that's right
said into the Zeitgeist so that's very
very helpful
um there are a couple of other things I
mean obviously we're going to see Bill
Barr we're going to see Ivanka and Jared
in every single one of these that's
going to happen now that they they know
full well that those are the things that
will be clipped and they are going to
sprinkle them up somebody call them
catnip
and I think that's right I I think
having these clips of uh and and we're
also starting to see
the tension between Jared and other
people in the White House Circle people
are going to be throwing each other
under the bus or in the case of Brad
parskali under his uh what was it uh he
had a hundred and fifty thousand dollar
Range Rover Mercedes-Benz he had all
these cars and you heard Bill stepey and
say I had to come in and clean up this
mess this terrible campaign it was
irresponsible at 115 days that was Brad
parscow uh and he was thrown under the
bus all of this is what we might hope
for in this process where they are
forced in public to turn against each
other and they're gonna now hear what
they said in depositions that that
attacks one Trump Insider uh from
another and that that part's gonna play
out you know one of the things that I
thought and I said this I think to you
uh when after the first hearing this
this idea that we saw Jared only for a
second but he basically said Pat
cipolloni the president's Council
through their negotiations with to come
and testify be a big get to get him
he called him a whiner
yard called him a whiner you think
that's going to motivate him to possibly
come in front of the committee I I kind
of think it will
I I hope there's I hope there's a lot of
these characters that get in front of
the committee um I don't know how how
good their excuses are going to be and
what we're going to see from these other
um hearings but I back to Bill step in
for a second that you mentioned I
actually think his non-appearance today
is probably uh worse for him and team
Trump after seeming seeing some of the
clips I think I think it did not help
the case that he wasn't there oh yeah um
to defend his testimony yeah and frankly
he would have been a hostile witness
were he there uh you know again show me
the baby
I I don't believe a word of this excuse
but but I thought the committee handled
really well we wish we hope for the
health of the trial whatever all of that
was the right way to handle it but what
you saw that they did guys is they put
together
um very much on the Fly because they had
to do this in the last couple of hours
they pulled the clips that uh zoloftrun
who let's give her credit she's been
doing this a long time she's very good
at it and Zoe immediately said just what
what you would do let's go to clip 14.
right right pull that clip list together
on the Fly this morning and what did
they do they also picked out a picture I
thought this was uh illustrative of how
they were really prepared for every
eventuality they had a picture of Bill
steffian with his head against the wall
you mean that calendar photo
all right you know I actually I actually
text Gabe when that picture came up I
said it it looks like he's longing for
Ivanka Trump in that picture like he's
you know I don't know what was going on
in the picture but uh it was a beautiful
Google image I don't know what exact
Search terms they put in to find that
image of him but it was it was it was um
perfect a perfect picture in a lot of
ways but if it wasn't a calendar photo
it was a my head is up against the wall
I'm banging it on
um because this is an insane position
for me to be in so you know we we saw a
couple of other things we saw a great uh
line that stepian used actually where in
talking about Giuliani having the
president's year uh
and his drink and his drink event he was
drinking for two the president or Trump
let's not call him the president whoever
that was who was in that office for four
years that guy claims never to drink
let's assume that that he can act drunk
without drinking Giuliani drank for him
he had yeah he had his drink as well so
the step in phrase that as after a while
I realized that you know there was team
Giuliani and team normal
team normal is going to be a big phrase
now and and so locked in repeating that
the team normal uh is is really anyone
who's remotely connected to facts right
and I think they're gonna make t-shirts
like oh number one
I'm I'm I think uh jerseys I think the
uh Midas merch group but there you go I
don't know I don't know if the suits are
listening but you better get your team
normal Jersey
go ahead I was gonna say as soon as they
said Team normal I immediately had a
flashback to Young Frankenstein and
thought of just team Abby normal
that's the type of crew that we're
dealing with all right
I think we we might have lost David
there on his audio for he froze
um we're gonna go back to the hearing as
we see the uh the witnesses for panel
too if we if we get David back here
um they were they were
um setting up for the panel two looks
like the election attorney uh Benjamin
Ginsburg uh BJ pack the former U.S
attorney of north of the Northern
District of Georgia and then also Al
Schmidt the former Philadelphia city uh
commissioner and I'm sure this testimony
gave is going to be
um something to see because the last one
it was like the squirrel turds part of
the oh yeah of the committee like we had
Sydney Powell we had drunk Rudy Giuliani
and you know all these characters 2
000 mules like all this stuff going and
so the squirrel third part of the of the
hearing was was the first part this is
probably going to be more serious and a
tick tock of more of the serious actual
facts that's going on here and we see
Benny Thompson
emerging here in the committee following
him so I'm sure we're going to get
underway here in just a few minutes but
I expect this to be a much more serious
type Tick Tock here than the last yeah
yeah uh Drunken Squirrel turd type I
mean the last one was like an
intervention for Rudy Giuliani wow it
was everyone coming to town and saying
he was drunk he was drunk he was
inebriated he was under the influence
well let's let's see what we got with
the the second round with the panel two
here uh let's get back to the committee
and here we go
foreign
will be in order
I now welcome our second panel of
witnesses
we're joined today by B.J pack Al Smith
and Ben Ginsburg
Mr pack is the former United States
Attorney for the Northern District of
Georgia
Mr Smith is a former City Commissioner
for the city of Philadelphia where he
served for more than 10 years Mr
Ginsburg is one of the leading election
law attorneys in the country and has
represented Republican presidential
candidates in election litigation dating
back to twenty two thousand
where he represented George W bush and
the bush Vigor litigation
I will now sway in our Witnesses
please stand and raise your right hand
do you swear our firm on the penalty of
perjury that the testimony you're about
to give is the truth the whole truth and
nothing but the truth so help you God
thank you please be seated
let the record reflect the witnesses
answered in the affirmative
pursuant to section 5c8 of house
resolution 503 I now recognize the young
woman from California Miss loffman for
questions
thank you Mr chairman
before the break I think you all heard
Mr Barr and Mr Donahue talk about the
false claims that Mr Trump and his
supporters made about suitcases of fake
ballots in Georgia we have a witness
here today who thoroughly investigated
that issue Mr pack I want to thank you
for appearing before us today you were
appointed by President Trump to serve as
a U.S attorney for the Northern District
of Georgia and you serve from 2017 until
January of 2021. you were the lead
Federal prosecutor there and worked for
the Department of Justice under then
attorney general Bill Barr now were you
ever asked by attorney general Barr to
investigate claims of voter fraud in the
2020 election and if so what were those
claims
thank you Congressman Lofgren thank you
for the question uh approximately
December 4th I believe of 2020
attorney general Barr and I had a
conversation about an unrelated case the
case that issued
at the end of the conversation Mr Barr
had asked me if I had seen a certain
videotape that was being reported in the
news where Mr Giuliani in a Senate
subcommittee hearing that was held the
day before May 3rd showed a videotape of
a purportedly a security tape at the
State Farm Arena in Atlanta which is
also in Fulton County in the city of
Atlanta
I'm sorry city of yes
at the time Mr R asked me that he had
made a public statement that he had not
seen any
um
widespread election fraud that would
question the outcome of the election
and because of the videotape and the
serious allegation that Mr Giuliani was
making respect to these suitcase flow
ballots supported in the the video
he asked me to find out what I could
about it because he had envisioned that
in some days after our call that he was
going to go to the White House for a
meeting and then that issue might come
up he asked me to make it a priority to
get to the bottom of just try to
substantiate the allegation made by Mr
Giuliani
uh thank you I understand that Georgia
Secretary of State's office
investigated those State Farm Arena
allegations and didn't find any evidence
of fraud what did you find when your
office convected uh conducted its own
investigation
we found that the suitcase full of
ballots alleged black suitcase that was
being seen pulled from under the table
was actually an official lock box where
ballots were kept safe
we found out that there was a mistake in
terms of those misunderstanding that
they were done counting ballots or
tallying ballots for the night and the
the partisan uh Watchers that was
assigned by each of the respected
parties were announced to send home but
once they realized mistake someone from
Secretary of State's office had
indicated that no no we're not done for
the night you need to go ahead and
continue counting so once they packed up
the lock box full of ballots they
brought back the official ballot box
again and continued to tally the ballots
from that from that the lock box
um
unfortunately
during the Senate hearing Mr Giuliani
only played a clip that showed them
pulling out the official ballot box from
under the table and referring to that as
a Smoking Gun of a fraud in in Fulton
County but in actuality in review of the
entire video it showed that that was
actually an official ballot box that
would kept underneath the tables and
then they we saw them pack up because
the announcement that they thought they
were done for the night and then once
the announcement was made that you
should continue counting they brought
the ballot pack out and they continued
to count we interviewed the FBI
interviewed the individuals that are
depicted in the the videos
properly were double triple counting of
the ballots and determined that nothing
irregular happen in the county and the
allegations made by Mr Giuliani were
false
thank you very much I'd like to play
again
um a testimony from Mr Donahue who
appeared before the committee before
today
Mr Donahue you we talked it so much
about whether or not the White House or
the president was informed about the
Antrim report
um on the results of the investigations
the interviews that have gone on on
Fulton County
um how would those results have been
communicated to the White House to the
president
I don't know how they were initially
communicated I do know that they came up
in subsequent conversations with the
president and Dad Rose and I essentially
told him we looked into that and it's
just not true
okay so he wasn't he was informed
I told the president myself that several
times in several conversations that
these allegations about Alex being
smuggled in in the suitcase and run
through the machine several times it was
not true that we looked at we looked at
the video we interviewed what the system
was not
Mr pack after you left the U.S
attorney's Office on January 4th 2021
did the next U.S attorney there I think
Mr Trump's personal pick Bobby Christine
did he investigate any remaining claims
of Fraud and if so did he find any
evidence that supported the president's
claims of voter fraud
is my understanding that Mr Christine
continued any investigations that were
pending at the time of my departure but
he was unable to find any evidence of
fraud that affected the outcome of the
election
so after investigating the presidents
and Mr giuliani's claims about voter
fraud in Georgia is it your view today
that there was no evidence of widespread
fraud sufficient to undermine confidence
in the outcome of the election in
Georgia that is correct
thank you Mr pack and I want to thank
you also for the service that you've
given to our country we appreciate that
next I'd like to turn to president
Trump's false allegations about election
Integrity in Philadelphia the Attorney
General discussed these allegations at
some length
you know the idea
the president has repeatedly suggested
that there was some kind of outpouring
of unexpected votes in inner city areas
like Philadelphia as recently as January
13th when he worked off the NPR set
he was asked by the uh interviewer and
what's you know what's your evidence of
Fraud and he said more people voted to
Philadelphia than there were voters and
that was absolutely rubbish uh the
turnout in Philadelphia was in line with
the state's turnout and in fact it was
not as as impressive as many Suburban
counties and uh there was nothing uh
strange about the Philadelphia uh
turnout it wasn't like there was all
these unexpected votes that came out in
Philadelphia so
you know I think once you actually look
at the votes and then
there's an obvious explanation he you
know for example in Pennsylvania Trump
ran weaker than the Republican ticket
General he ran weaker than two of the
state
uh candidates he ran weaker than the
Congressional delegate delegation
running for federal Congress and he ran
weaker than the Republic I think
I haven't looked at this recently but he
generally was
a weak element on the Republican ticket
so that does not suggest that the
election was stolen by fraud how about
Pennsylvania
we were talking to the US attorney in
Philadelphia about an alleged
discrepancy between a number of absentee
ballots issued in the number of ballots
right that's right you know that was a
one of the big ones for a period of time
I think I think that was a Gettysburg by
Giuliani or something like that but it
kept on being repeated and I found it
annoying because
uh
I didn't seem that it was right so I
called
I called McSwain
and uh
he got back to me he said no the problem
is that extriana threw out a
throughout this number and what he did
was he mixed apples and oranges he took
the number of applications for the
Republican primary and he compared it to
the number of absentee votes
cast in the general election but once
you actually go and look and compare
apples to apples there's no discrepancy
and uh you know that's one of the I I
think at some point I covered that with
the president
we have another witness here uh today
who has detailed knowledge about the
election process in Philadelphia Mr
Schmidt at the time of the 2020
presidential election you were serving
as the only Republican member of
Philadelphia's three-member City
commission which is responsible for
overseeing elections throughout the city
is that correct
that's correct Congress person so
president Trump made numerous claims
regarding fraudulent voting practices in
Philadelphia including the claim that
dead people were voting in fact Mr
Giuliani told Pennsylvania state
legislators that 8 000 dead people voted
in Pennsylvania you investigated those
claims of voter fraud
can you tell us what you found
Not only was there not evidence of 8 000
dead voters voting in Pennsylvania there
wasn't evidence of eight
we took seriously every case that was
referred to us no matter how Fantastical
no matter how absurd and took every one
of those seriously including these
as it turns out even Mr Trump's campaign
lawyers knew that the dead voter claims
weren't valid
I guess the crooks in Philadelphia are
disappointed in this they only submitted
8021
ballads from dead people mail-in ballots
for dead people probably easier for dead
people to submit male imbalance than it
is to vote in person
Rudy was at this stage of his life and
the same ability to manage things at
this level or not
and obviously I think Bernie Carrick
publicly said it they never proved the
allegations that they were making and
they were trying to develop
Mr Schmidt on November 11 2020
president Trump tweeted about you saying
and here's a quote a guy named Al
Schmidt a Philadelphia commissioner and
so-called Republican or Rhino is being
used big time by the fake news media to
explain how honest things were with
respect to the election in Philadelphia
he refuses to look at a mountain of
corruption dishonesty we win
as a result of that tweet and the CNN
interview you gave where you stated the
dead voter claims in Pennsylvania were
false you and your staff were subjected
to disturbing threats can you tell us
about that
the threats prior to that tweet and on
some level it feels almost silly to talk
about a tweet but we can really see the
impact they have because prior to that
the threats were pretty General in
nature
corrupt election officials in
Philadelphia are going to get what's
coming to them
you're with the Second Amendment is for
you're walking into the lion's den all
sorts of things like that after the
president tweeted at me by name
calling me out the way that he did
um the threats became much more specific
much more graphic
uh and included not just me by name uh
but included members of my family by
name their ages our address pictures of
our home just every bit of detail that
you could imagine that was what changed
with that tweet
behind me are redacted threats that you
received that you provided to the
committee now we redacted portions of
the text to protect your family
Mr Schmidt I I think I speak for all of
my colleagues when I say we are deeply
sorry for what you and your loved ones
have been through and I also want to
thank you for your service to your
country and for standing up for the rule
of law
I want to thank both Mr pack and Mr
Schmidt for their service their
testimony and for standing up for the
rule of law
now I'd like to turn to another subject
um
the courts in our country
provide a legitimate venue for campaigns
to challenge what they view as a regular
election practices now boards have the
final say on how the law applies to
those challenges we have a renowned
legal expert here to address the Trump
campaign's activities in court Mr
Ginsburg you've spent your entire career
representing Republicans in election
related litigation you served as the
National Council on Republican
Presidential campaigns in 2000 in 2004
and in 2012 you played a key role in the
2000 Florida recount that led to the
Supreme Court's decision in Bush Igor
who served as the co-chair of the
presidential commission on Election
Administration I think it's fair to say
you're the most prominent Republican
lawyer who's litigated in the election
field now you you've analyzed the Trump
campaign's litigation pretty carefully
what's the like normal process for
post-election litigation how is the
Trump campaigns different from the kinds
of post-election litigation you've been
involved in and know about
in the normal course of things any
campaign on the night of the election
and the days after we'll do a couple of
different things one is that they'll
analyze Precinct results to look for
abnormalities in the results and they'll
send people to those precincts to ask
more questions
secondly uh all campaigns will have poll
Watchers and poll workers and observers
in the polling place and so campaigns
will talk uh to those people if they saw
any irregularities that could cause
problems in the election now the Trump
campaign talked pre-election about
having 50 000 poll workers so presumably
they did have eyes on the ground in all
these places and so in the normal course
of things a campaign will analyze the
reports that come in Trump campaign had
a couple of basic problems however
number one the 2020 election was not
close in 2000 that was 537 and close in
this election the most narrow margin was
10 000 and something in in Arizona and
you just don't make up that those sorts
of numbers in recounts and when the
claims of Fraud and irregularities uh
were made you've heard very compelling
testimony for Mr stepian from Matt
Morgan from Alex Cannon about those
claims and how uh they didn't believe
them and so that put the Trump campaign
on sort of a process of bringing cases
without the actual evidence that you
have to have in which the process is
designed to bring out
so are you aware of any instance in
which a court found the Trump campaign's
fraud claims to be credible
now there was there was never that
instance uh in all the cases that were
brought and I've looked at the more than
60 that include more than 180 counts and
no the simple fact is that the Trump
campaign did not make its case
the select committee has identified 62
post-election lawsuits filed by the
Trump campaign and his allies between
November 4th 2020 and January 6
2021. those cases resulted in 61 losses
and only a single Victory which actually
didn't affect the outcome for either
candidate
despite those 61 losses president Trump
and his allies claimed that the courts
refused to hear them out and as a result
they never had their day in court Mr
Ginsburg what do you say about the
claims that Mr Trump wasn't given an
opportunity to provide the evidence they
had of voter fraud did they have in fact
did they have their day in court they
did have their day in court about half
of those cases that you mentioned were
dismissed at the procedural stage for a
lack of standing the proper people
didn't bring the case or there wasn't
sufficient evidence and it got
dismissed on a motion to dismiss
but in the other there was discussion of
the merits that was that was contained
in the complaints and in no instance did
a court find that the charges of fraud
were real and it's also worth noting
that even if the Trump campaign
complained that it did not have its stay
in court there had been post-election
reviews in each of the six Battleground
states that could have made a difference
and those ranged from these somewhat
farcical cyber ninjas case in Arizona to
the Michigan Senate report that was
mentioned earlier the hand recount in
Georgia the Mr pack addressed and in
each one of those instances there was no
credible evidence of fraud produced by
the Trump campaign or his supporters
thank you you know as Mr Ginsburg has
explained there are no cases where the
Trump campaign was able to convince a
court that there was widespread fraud or
irregularities in the 2020 election over
and over judges appointed by Democrats
and Republicans alike directly rebooted
this false narrow narrative they called
out the Trump campaign's lack of
evidence for its claims and the judges
did that even in cases where they could
have simply thrown out the lawsuit
without writing a word
foreign
you can see behind me a few excerpts
from the decisions in these 62 cases
the Trump campaign's lack of evidence
was criticized by judges across the
political Spectrum in Pennsylvania a
trump-appointed judge concluded quote
charges require specific allegations and
proof we have neither here another Trump
appointed judge warned that if cases
like these succeeded quote any
disappointed loser in a presidential
election able to hire a team of clever
lawyers could flag claim deviations from
election results and cast out on
election results the list goes on and on
allegations are called quote an
amalgamation of theories conjecture and
speculation in another strained legal
arguments without Merit
unsupported by evidence derived from
wholly unreliable sources a fundamental
and obvious misreading of the
Constitution
the rejection of President Trump's
litigation efforts was overwhelming 22
federal judges appointed by Republican
presidents including 10 appointed by
President Trump himself and at least 24
elected or appointed Republican state
judges dismissed the president's claims
at least 11 lawyers have been referred
for disciplinary proceedings due to bad
faith and Basil's efforts to undermine
the outcome of the 2020 presidential
election Rudy Giuliani had his license
to practice law suspended in New York
and just this week a newly filed
complaint will potentially make his
suspension from practicing law in D.C
permanent
and as we've
just heard from perhaps the most
preeminent Republican election lawyer in
recent history
the Trump campaign's unprecedented
effort to overturn its election laws in
court was a deeply damaging abuse of the
judicial process as stated by U.S
District Court Judge David Carter this
was quote a coup in search of a legal
Theory
thank you Mr chairman I yield back
I want to thank our Witnesses for
joining us today
the members of the select committee may
have additional questions for today's
Witnesses and we ask that you respond
expeditiously in writing to those
questions
without objection members will be
permitted 10 business days to submit
statements for the record including
opening remarks and additional questions
for the witnesses the second panel of
witnesses is now dismissed
without objection the chair recognizes
the general woman from California Miss
Lofgren for a closing statement
thank you
thank you Mr chairman now that we
understand the litigation efforts by
President Trump and his allies I'd like
to present additional actions taken by
the Trump campaign during this time
president Trump continued to push the
stolen election narrative even though he
and his allies knew that their
litigation efforts making the same claim
had failed that's worth pointing out
that litigation uh generally does not uh
continue past the Safe Harbor date of
December 14th but the fact that this
litigation went on well that decision
makes more sense when you consider the
Trump campaign's fundraising tactics
because if the litigation had stopped on
December 14th there would have been no
fight to defend the election and no
clear path to continue to raise millions
of dollars Mr chairman at this time I'd
ask for unanimous consent to include in
the record a video presentation
describing how president Trump used the
lies he told to raise millions of
dollars from the American people these
fundraising schemes were also part of
the effort to disseminate the false
claims of election fraud without
objections Amanda Wick and I'm senior
investigative council with the house
select committee to investigate the
January 6 attack on the United States
capital
between election day and January 6th the
Trump campaign sent millions of
fundraising emails to Trump supporters
sometimes as many as 25 a day
the emails claimed the quote left-wing
mob was undermining the election
implored supporters to quote step up to
protect the Integrity of the election
and encourage them to quote fight back
but as the select committee has
demonstrated the Trump campaign knew
these claims of voter fraud were false
yet they continued to barrage small
dollar donors of emails encouraging them
to donate to something called the
official election defense fund
the select committee discovered no such
fund existed
you're afraid to say the election
defects fund was another I think we've
called it a marketing tactic yes and
tell us about these funds marketing
tactics uh just a topic matter
where money could potentially go to be
how money could potentially be used
claims that the election was stolen were
so successful president Trump and his
allies raised 250 million dollars nearly
a hundred million dollars in the first
week after the election
on November 9th 2020 president Trump
created a separate entity called the
save America path most of the money
raised went to this newly created pack
not to election related litigation the
select committee discovered that the
save America pact made millions of
dollars of contributions to pro-trump
organizations including one million
dollars to Trump Chief of Staff Mark
Meadows charitable Foundation one
million dollars to the America First
policy Institute a conservative
organization which employs several
former Trump Administration officials
204
857 dollars to the Trump Hotel
Collection and over five million dollars
to event strategies Inc the company that
ran president Trump's January 6th rally
on the ellipse oh is here today do not
want to see our election Victory stolen
by a bold and radical left Democrats
which is what they're doing the evidence
developed by the select committee
highlights how the Trump campaign
aggressively pushed false election
claims to fundraise
telling supporters it would be used to
fight voter fraud that did not exist
the emails continued through January 6
even as president Trump spoke on the
Olympics
30 minutes after the last fundraising
email was sent the capital was briefed
all right
every American is entitled and
encouraged to participate in our
electoral process political fundraising
is part of that
small dollar donors use scarce
disposable income to support candidates
and causes of their choosing to make
their voices heard and those donors
deserve the truth about what those funds
will be used for
throughout the committee's investigation
we found evidence that the Trump
campaign and its surrogates misled
donors as to where their funds would go
and what they would be used for So Not
only was there the big lie there was the
big rip-off
donors deserve to know where their funds
are really going they deserve better at
what president Trump and his team did Mr
chairman I yield back
without objection the chair recognizes
the gentlewoman from Wyoming this Cheney
for a closing statement thank you very
much Mr chairman Ms chairman I would
like to thank all of our Witnesses today
uh and I'd also like to uh in particular
wish Mr stepian and and his family all
the best on the arrival of of a new baby
today's hearing Mr chairman was very
narrowly focused and in the coming days
you will see the committee move on
to president Trump's broader planning
for January 6th including his plan to
corrupt the Department of Justice and
his detailed planning with lawyer John
Eastman to pressure the vice president
state legislature's state officials and
others to overturn the election
let me leave you today with one clip to
preview what you will see in one of our
hearings to come
this is the testimony of White House
lawyer Eric Hershman
John Eastman called Mr Hershman the day
after January 6th and here is how that
conversation went
I said to him
are you out of your open mind
right I said I
could I only want to hear two words
coming out of your mouth for now on
orderly transition
thank you Mr chairman I yield back
at the conclusion of last week's hearing
we showed you a video of rioters
explaining why they had come to
Washington on January 6th
it was because Donald Trump told them to
be here
today we heard about some of the lies
Donald Trump embraced and Amplified when
it became clear he didn't have the
numbers of votes to win the election
we heard about how officials at
different levels of government exploit
claims of Fraud and found no evidence
yet the former president continued to
repeat those false claims over and over
again
today we'll end things where we did on
Thursday
back on January 6th hearing words of
individuals who wanted to stop the
transfer of power
we know they were there because of
Donald Trump now we hear some of the
things they believed
without objection I enter into the
record a video presentation
I know exactly what's going on right now
big election they think they're gonna
[ __ ] cheat outside of our boat with
Congress [ __ ] Biden in office it
ain't [ __ ] happening today but
who voted yes sir
did early it went well except for a
can't really trust the software Dominion
software all over we voted and right at
the top right hand corner of the
Dominion voting machine that we used
there was a Wi-Fi symbol with five bars
so that most definitely connected
without a doubt so they stole that from
us twice we're not doing it anymore
we're not taking it anymore so we're
standing up we're here and whatever
happens we're not laying down again 200
[Music]
000 people that weren't even registered
voted
and you can't stand there and tell me
that it worked
I don't want to tell you that what we're
doing is right
but if the election is being stolen what
is it going to take
the chair request those in the hearing
room remain seated until the Capitol
Police have excluded members from the
room
without objection the committee stands
adjoint
thank you
there you have the
adjournment of the committee for day two
of the January 6 select
committee hearings
on June 13th Monday we were 45 minutes
late
but we finally got got into the mix here
and I want to bring Gabe Sanchez my
co-host and executive producer here
um
howdy wow wow wow wow what uh this the
second half there was It was kind of
interesting I wonder what the escort out
was about that seems um different from
what we've seen before yeah they're uh I
don't know what's there a possibility of
something being talked about or I don't
know anything I'm not sure if something
happened yesterday or the on Thursday
after so now this is like new protocol
or I don't know it uh well they they
hadn't uh they he didn't say that during
the break so
um that everyone remained seated until
we uh get back to the uh the point so
what we see here them ramping up
um we're gonna go to
um some coverage here with some guests
but I want I want to um
I wanna I wanna tell you that uh we
would appreciate if you guys go ahead
and subscribe uh to the Midas Touch
YouTube channel here you guys will find
all kinds of different podcasts here on
the YouTube channel of Midas Touch uh
the Midas touch podcast the legal AF
podcast uh Kremlin file we have uh
politics girl with Lee McGowan and then
my uncle with Michael Cohen also here on
the Midas Touch YouTube channel don't
forget to also subscribe to our YouTube
channel the Tony Michaels podcast you
will find our show every single day
every single weekday live two hours
Monday through Friday this is our
regular viewing time even though we're
in a special coverage
um we usually go till two Eastern we
start at noon Eastern 11 Central nine
Pacific Monday through Friday for two
hours also download all those podcasts
on Apple Spotify Google wherever you
find your podcast make sure to go over
there
um it's um we would appreciate that if
you guys helped us out we we really like
having you guys for the coverage we've
had thousands of people tune in not just
on Thursday but today Gabe um it's been
a great success over here I think there
are more people watching today than
Thursday what's it really okay well
that's good I don't know I don't know I
have to look at the numbers again I mean
today we're over 15 000. right yeah well
I think at one point across channels we
were up over 16 000 people watching live
I know we had uh 200 250 000 people that
were total view of the uh of last week's
from this Midas Touch media channel here
um whether you downloaded it or you
watched it on YouTube or Facebook we
appreciate all that and to show our
appreciation mindless touch has given us
a promo code
store.mindustouch.com 10 off just use
the promo code Justice again use the
promo code Justice to get did get your
famous minus touch yeah merchandise over
there we have a couple political
strategists that are joining us um you
know David Bender has been here on
Thursday and today and we also have my
favorite political strategist Dr Rachel
bittickoffer she is she is one of my
favorite
um Rachel how are you
ah man that was riveting musty TV Midas
touch screen uh streaming right yeah
absolutely so tell tell me tell me what
you thought about
um today's uh witness assessment there's
a lot of key phrases coming out of this
as when there's there's big massive
dumps yeah awesome jumps ready
first game took note of big massive
dumps right of course of course of
course so tell us what your your take is
your quick your quick take on what
today's hearing meant than the witnesses
yeah so to remind people what the
Strategic purpose of these committees
this committee process is is a couple
fold right number one deliver this
information in a format different than
the impeachment trials so that people
might actually get some primary source
exposure right and they've really
delivered on that end right uh the other
end though of course is to explain or to
give for merit Garland for the doj a
public version of the evidence that is
out there I mean this is the public
facing and and what even the committee
admitted they are holding things back
public facing account of what happened
in 2020 and what they're trying to do in
this public account is explained to the
public potential criminality and today
was all about showing I think one thing
I really expected which was the intent
to lie to create a fraud lie to fuel the
energy and the cover on the political
right right to allow them to not
transfer power okay because you have to
have public sentiment on your side for
that and the big lies serve that purpose
always but the other one is to show that
it was intent that they knew the whole
time that they were lying and I really
didn't expect that they were going to
work in the fraud elements but there is
definitely some very um strong potential
of uh that all that fundraising
especially the stuff that happened after
they said you know mid-December is they
were committing fraud if they knew that
the election was not rigged and that
they were out of legal challenges and
begging money to to continue the legal
fight that's a big problem so it was
really
um I think well done again I think it's
good that they're breaking this [ __ ] up
it gives us time to you know gnaw on the
bones and Bill Barr is definitely a man
that does not want to go to jail oh man
and he absolutely destroyed Donald Trump
today and 2 000 mules and the big lie I
want to bring in David Bender to to see
what he he thought of this second half
this panel to David tell us what your
thoughts are on this second half first
let me say Rachel good to see you again
it's so good to see you again too David
to be back on and and we get to be
talking about dumps all at the same time
thank you for writing that down just in
case it was forgotten so we don't forget
it you know right right that would be
number two on the list uh
definitely intended but number one on
the list is a lie or is a phrase that
Zoloft can use twice the big rip-off
and we're going to hear that a lot now
and that's going to be the corollary to
the big light frankly the big lie has
gotten a little stale people can't hear
that anymore but right big rip-off
when it's coming out of the pockets of
of you know people on Social Security
who are giving their money to the Trump
campaign and she made a point of saying
people can barely afford to give are
giving these dollars and none of the
money is going where they thought it was
going now this is not news to us this is
Donald Trump's entire life but but this
is now something that is going to be
clipped out and shown to people and
hopefully it's going to have an impact
when they realize that this is and I I
think to Rachel's point there there
could be some real interesting
litigation not litigation prosecution
for this action this is another part of
what could be a criminal referral if
they are fraudulently uh reaching out to
their donors to fund something that
doesn't exist exactly is as real as
Trump University
uh it's it's those the choices so look I
I thought one of the things that was
really interesting is if you think about
this witness list including Bill stepian
and I'm going to stipulate now okay I
believe there's a baby I do I wasn't
sure before we went in if it was a fake
baby or a real baby I now I he'll
produce the baby we'll we'll find out
but I'll tell you one thing that was
interesting all three of those Witnesses
and all four had stepped in arrived were
Republicans every single person there
was a republican we now see what they're
doing uh I didn't know this until just
this morning and checking BJ pack before
he was an appointee uh to uh the
Department of Justice as a as an
attorney was an elected Republican
official in Georgia this these are all
people who come out of the Republican
Party Ben Ginsburg who gave us George W
bush thank you very much the gift that
keeps on giving uh but these are people
of impeccable Republican credentials and
that's what the committee is going to do
it's going to make it very clear
including the doj witnesses will have
including Pence's people coming up after
that but this is not a partisan Witch
Hunt this is a bipartisan fully
Republican bill bar and all of the other
people are Republicans through and
through and they've had enough
um is that uh Jamie Ross yeah I'm gonna
I'm gonna go to Jamie let's listen to
what he has to say explain the facts you
were trying to lay out today what were
you trying to make sure people picked up
today
well it's very important for everyone to
see Not only was the big lie a big lie
but Donald Trump must have known
it was a big lie unless as uh William
Barr put it he was detached from reality
but we're going to assume that the
president of the United States uh was
connected to reality and in that case he
had to listen to the Attorney General of
the United States all of the White House
lawyers the campaign lawyers the
campaign advisors they were all telling
the same thing it was over he had lost
the election and he goes out instead and
says the opposite that he had won the
election now
oh well I to me it doesn't make much
difference it's just a fact that
obviously came out during the
questioning but it it does uh further
erode whatever credibility you might
have placed in his Judgment at that
point
when it gave that presentation briefly
at the end had the committee and its
investigation find any evidence of trump
or his family members personally taking
the contributions they were seeking for
their own personal use or any evidence
of uh wire fraud or financial fraud
relating to these donations I'm not
going to comment on that Congressman
Chaney teased Johnny Smith's involvement
in that clip you played at the end can
you lay out a little bit about Eastman's
role and how you guys are going to
explore that coming up okay so uh
after it was clear to Donald Trump that
he had lost the election he began to
engage in increasingly desperate in an
increasingly illegitimate efforts to
overthrow Joe Biden's majority in the
Electoral College now as we said today
it was perfectly legit to go into court
and they lost more than 60 cases
including from eight judges Donald Trump
had nominated himself to the bench
um so what we have is an overwhelming
meticulous record in court that he lost
the election and there was no electoral
fraud there was no electoral corruption
well then uh the Mr Eastman makes his
appearance and Eastman's point was that
the election wasn't really over because
they could conduct the so-called Green
Bay sweep if they could just get vice
president Pence to step outside of his
constitutional role and nullify
Electoral College votes coming in from
the states then they could keep it going
I either have Trump declared the Victor
in the joint session of Congress or kick
the whole thing into the House of
Representatives for a so-called
contingent election we're going to spell
out what exactly Eastman's Green Bay
sweep was all about and we will show
that that was utterly fraudulent too
thank you
well then earlier kind of today's
discussion
it's gotten very invested
uh expect to see you dig into personally
yeah well and we're all focusing on
different elements of the plan to
overthrow the 2020 presidential election
and uh the part that I've been focused
on is the mobilization of the mob and
the domestic violent extremist groups
the proud boys and The Oath Keepers and
so on uh and uh so that that will be
several hearings away but that's what
I've been spending most of my time on
will there be more money that's sent
will there be more information on the
money that trumpets received which they
received after the election and they
received from you know spouting these
elections well here's the way I would
encourage people to think about it and
think about any election you've ever
followed participated in or watched
um once someone loses the election it
becomes almost impossible for them to
raise money winners can usually keep
raising money because they're going to
be in office and there will be another
election coming but losers find the
money dry up immediately well Donald
Trump was told by all of these people
including the Attorney General of the
United States that he had lost the
election and it was essentially hopeless
for him but he found a way to keep the
money flowing in and that was to claim
that he'd actually won the election and
that it was being stolen from him and uh
as uh as Ms Lofgren pointed out at the
end there was more than 200 million
dollars that came in after the election
was over that's an extraordinary sum of
money because people were invested in
the idea that he was still somehow
fighting this in court with a commit to
be sort of releasing more information
about those fundraising and what that
achieved
um I believe there will be more
information released again where you
know we're trying to compress a lot of
information into each of these
individual hearings but I I believe
there will be more information available
so your theory of the case is that
President Trump would scripted his
voters well the theory of our case is
spelled out in all of our hearings
um you know the motives of the president
are going to be up to the people to
decide but from our perspective whatever
the motive was some people suggested
it's Financial some people have
suggested it was political some have
suggested it was narcissistic some have
suggested that he was detached from
reality whatever the motive the point is
that he clearly had the intention that
he acted upon to try to overthrow the
result of the 2020 presidential election
and as anybody will teach you in a
criminal law class what matters is your
intent not your motive the motive can
become relevant to demonstrating that
you have an intent and it's clearly of
interest to people in a democracy about
someone's character but ultimately it
was his intent to overthrow the results
of the 2020 election that is so critical
is there any frustration that you didn't
receive the rnc's emails through
Salesforce
um
but yeah you know I can't even remember
specifically what that oh oh um look we
wanted to get all the information we you
know we've asked for but we have been
able to develop a pretty clear portrait
of what happened from the information we
got to bring back the criminal law isn't
being detached from reality and
affirmative defense I'm sorry
in affirmative defense to what to to the
government uh well
um there's an insanity defense uh at the
federal level
um but uh as far as I know president
Trump has never asserted an insanity
defense to any of this I mean he
continues to say that he won the
election I think that we have ended that
lie with our first uh two hearings I
think America understands Donald Trump
lost the election Joe Biden won it by
more than seven million votes and
everything else is just disinformation
propaganda and conspiracy theory have
you heard what else on the commission
any evidence of witness intimidation
thus far
not that I'm aware of but I don't know
I've been sent
though what what is the nature of this
dress
you know but I'd rather not comment on
that
and I think I'm scheduled for another
I've got to go someplace but thank you
very much
any question which one is that I I
um I've been focused on the relationship
uh so here we have I've been focus on
the mobilization of the mob and the
domestic violent extremist groups the
proud Boys The Oath Keepers he appears
to be kind of repeating
um some some other
um questions that he had
um
it see it seems it seems as if that um
that we may we may see some more um uh
interviews here and there but Jamie's
Jamie's trying to break away they're
they're again asking him some other
questions that he's been asked already
um what do you make of some of the
questions that he was that he was asking
more importantly what his answers were
there uh David you can go first well the
only thing I want to say is that he cuts
the chase I've never heard Donald Trump
assert that he was insane but if that
may be coming who knows Rachel you must
have loved that as much as I did I did I
wanna
I seen you laughing in the background
yes yes in fact there is a there is a
way for someone to plead Insanity at the
federal level
and and he'll do it and he'll say and uh
74 million people stand with me in
Insanity you're a majority and we're not
being heard and and crazy is the virtue
Rachel I've got to ask you a question
any numbers since the first hearing and
we know that the numbers had dropped yet
again and were below 50 percent of
people who thought overall that he was
culpable uh have you seen anything yet
that shows movement of the dial
conservative
that's a good question no I haven't
really seen anything that
um any polling on the first thing you
know I mean that's kind of interesting
actually now that I think about it
because of the delay oh you would think
some would be dropping right now in the
field right now somebody's here yeah
yeah I mean we'll know soon you know I
I'll tell you this like I've been
watching the generic ballot for any sign
of movement since Uvaldi and this and
abortion all kind of getting into the
public atmosphere because it takes time
for the row memo leak to you know and
we're still not seeing any movement on
the generic ballot but at the same time
guys I will say this with like the
economic [ __ ] that's happening in
America exactly it's like you know you
got to wonder if there is a God the
[ __ ] got some sick sense of
humor right because like the way that
Germany fell is economic Strife laid the
seeds for the National Socialist
movement to build momentum in the 20s
and like there's if you were to ask me
okay rage social these midterm
fundamentals in party out party
fundamentals hang an albatross around
the Democratic party's fortunes and now
I'm going to give you historically High
inflation and potentially a stock market
crash and recession
why don't I just move to
move I I I I'll be in Vancouver so yeah
me too me too
a lot of fun I want like Pacific
Northwest Canada not cold Canada you
know right
go together detached from reality there
you go but yeah no I mean you know
like that's not good dude like at all
you know your point this is people who
don't uh study history are going to
repeat it and we're studying history now
and we're seeing we're living history
yes but but the other part of it and
this is something you know yes there may
be a sick sense of humor in in in uh in
the heavens but here on Earth
right before the Watergate hearings
Nixon was at 55 60 approval he had won
49 states the year before in re-election
uh an epic re-election defeating George
McGovern
and nobody believed that the hearings
were going to have any traction at all
they didn't now I know this is a
different media environment I all of
these things stipulated
well you can't watch even a little clip
and everything there that we saw today
just like we saw Thursday was done in
digestible bites it can be excerpted
every and and you go doing it already
and and as you see I think in the break
I sent you some clips that have already
been pulled there are more coming and
all of those clips are going to make
their way through Tick Tock and
Instagram into the Zeitgeist yep and
we're gonna see some ability for people
to start
changing their their sort of premise of
what happened if it was a lie and if if
it was a rip-off and if a lot of these I
think it was fascinating at the very end
again were these people who came there
and that man saying looking at the
camera saying well and he's breathing
tear gas
and he's saying if if I know this is a
hard thing that we did maybe it was the
wrong thing to do but if they're
stealing our government right well what
choice do we have well they weren't
stealing your government they were lying
to you right and that's going to be the
meta message now they've been lying to
you and you are the Fall Guy for it yeah
well you know that that's a good point
because talking about big massive dumps
of Clips on social media I'm gonna use
that as often as I can in the next few
weeks big massive numbers
speaking of big massive dumps of of the
eclipse of these hearings on social
media I think what is important for
people understand when they watch these
clips and you and you discover either
you have plucked your your head out of
your ass and realized that you were lied
to or you knew this lie all along but
here's the evidence now
um I I want you to ask everyone around
you as you watch these clips and if you
watch them or talk about them it asked
are these the people that you want in
charge of your economy are these the
people you want in charge of your gas
prices are these the people who lied to
you who gifted you who continued to try
to sort your democracy and your vote in
your country are these the people that
you want in charge of anything anymore I
think that is the main question that
people really have to be focused on is
yes we do have inflation there are gas
prices are high there are a lot of
different causes for those things but
Joe Biden and the president and the
Democrats aren't the reason that that
the inflation is happening in Europe
that gas prices are the way they are
around the world it there are many
outside forces that are happening here
with our economy and the situation on
the world stage but here in this country
you can make a difference by saying what
is a lie and what is a big rip-off uh do
you steal from London's uh language
there and do you want another big
rip-off by putting putting these people
into power in the midterm to give them
the chance to continue to lie to you to
continue to spend
um the the big rip-off and I guess
that's probably the conversation that
needs to be had over those clips the big
massive dump of Clips well it also it
also ties into the narrative I'm trying
to sell the party writ large on running
on which is I mean which if we can
manifest in many different
different messages different topics
whereas but the the rep like you know
how the GOP always has the same refrain
to all their messaging no matter what
it's about which is fear of the
Democrats right so like our refrain that
I'm trying to teal this system to to run
is you simply can't trust this
Republican party you can't trust it with
your kids you can't trust it with your
bank account you can't trust it with
your money you can't trust it with your
health your security right and just keep
hammering that
Rachel that was Howard Dean's most
effective message you cannot trust
Republicans to manage your money
every time the economy has tanked it's
been under a republican now it's
happening under a Democrat based on
things that were started under
Republican if we had only because they
had one term David that's why so like
we're seeing the normal
it's just that we're seeing it where we
had the two terms disrupted which is
very atypical right except that I would
stipulate here or make the case that
because kovid was so badly mismanaged
under that one term and it created the
domino effect he lied about covet the
big lie that really created the problem
was when he was told in January and told
Bob Woodward this thing is deadly it's
Airborne it's going to spread and he
said this is bad Bob and then at the end
of February went out and said it's going
to be gone by Easter there's nothing
here he lied and we had two months where
we did nothing and that two months was
as deadly to the country economically
and in fact in a million lives lost as
anything that has ever happened
dereliction of Duty and now we're going
back to that same issue dereliction of
Duty during the three hours when he let
this play out these these actions had
consequences so our account economy is a
result of covet result of what happened
had it not had we done what other
countries have done and started dealing
with it honestly early on we wouldn't
have had nearly the problems that we
faced and the Joe Biden had to clean up
and Joe Biden did clean up but you know
you can't dig yourself out of a hole
that deep in with a Congress that is not
is only nominally I mean anyone calling
the Senate a Democratic Senate can't
count yeah I mean it's also I mean it's
also you bring up an excellent point
which is like under Republican
administrations there is typically a
downward growth that happens and then
Democrats come in and have to develop
social programs and other incentives to
get people back either working or you
know help them kind of uh get a step up
you know that actually does progress
themselves on a pathway to success and
then you know it's a back and forth this
ebb and flow cycle we see all the time
and then you bring up you know
Republicans that are like they will lie
they will cheat they will steal they
will do whatever they can to
um put themselves ahead of you as the
constituents or
fellow lawmakers or whoever it is and so
yeah you you look at like we we are
barely getting anything on on gun safety
and gun control
um that they've like by word have agreed
on and
um it's the bare minimum I think is what
they're willing to give you know
um and so you look at you know January
6th it's all a lie it's you know not
willing to admit that they were using
Trump and this whole uh fantasy of fraud
as a way to grift other people and take
advantage and take money and not even
have any sort of like oh maybe we
shouldn't do that maybe we shouldn't
[ __ ] over all of our Americans out in
the country right but they're like nah
I'm gonna get my money and everyone else
can go screw themselves right
speaking of [ __ ] did you notice that we
had warnings on all of the clips on the
first hearing but this last one was
replete with with probably the strongest
language we've heard with no no warning
yes
well they they knew we were broadcasting
it's now set the bar or the bill bar
that low right the [ __ ] is now a
normal word on national television now
apparently so it's [ __ ] I I do want to
make a point to what Richard was saying
earlier which is is in any other
Universe in any other time the right
message is that we go after them and we
talk about uh you know as as you said
each of these things should be pressed
hard on our part that's what the
Democrats should be doing
but the perception is uh fairly or
unfairly that Republicans are strong and
Democrats are weak
and that at the moment is really a
perception of Joe Biden uh and like it
or not that is the reality of an
undetached from reality we know that
so how does how do we get what happens
after Germany is in economic collapse
they go for a strong man
and whoever projects strength and that
is almost invariably someone who will
take away your rights in order to give
you Economic Security and as you know
most people are fine with that most
people a majority of people will say if
they had to trade some of their rights
to know that they could feed their
children
they're going to do that yeah and that
is where we are right now that's going
to be the Paradigm that Republicans are
pushing we're going to make you
economically secure you may not be able
to vote freely but that's not a big deal
because we're going to make sure that
this doesn't happen to you and if that
means you know whatever Liberties that
that are forsaken for that Economic
Security uh we're betting you'll make
that trade and I I'm afraid that they're
right unless we find someone in the
Democratic party who can a affirm
strength
and you know it's not going to come from
the sitting president I'm I'm afraid I
believe I I love it I really do uh it's
just not something you can create he
will be 80 at the end of November
so we have to figure out who can pick
that up uh that moment that Matthew
McConaughey had in the president's
briefing room
I I would love to see that on from if we
have to bring in a series of actors to
come in and make the case on economics
and make the case on strength of values
and how what it means to be a strong
America based on our values I don't care
how we communicate it we have to do
a [ __ ] better job right well you know
speaking of characters in a bit speaking
of characters in a better job I want to
bring in a couple Clips here this one
here is of Liz Cheney and she is uh she
says something about another character
who we know familiar uh Mr I call him
Grandpa farty mcsharty uh but other
people know him as Rudy Giuliani let's
let's listen
yeah
she's usually louder yeah
sound what's up
oh
I I gotta read your testimony Trump
rejected the advice of his campaign
experts on Election night
and instead followed the course
recommended by an apparently inebriated
Rudy Giuliani to just claim he won
and insist that the vote counting stop
the falsely claim everything was
fraudulent
he falsely told the American people that
the election was not legitimate in his
words quote a major fraud millions of
Americans believed him who will also
hear testimony that apparently
inebriated I couldn't you use that you
couldn't use that description with Rudy
just about like any time from the time
he gets up till the time he passes out
every time he's at the podium you know
it's like Rudy clearly had you know a
glass of whiskey or five and and then
people bring it up and he's like I'm not
I don't drink alcohol I will say this I
don't know if it was the committee
itself or it was the producer doing the
actual hearings
but I would say they're doing a very
very good job at finding these specific
sound bikes whether it's inebriated Rudy
Giuliani or its massive dumps or it's
normal team or or team normal or uh it's
the big rip-off but they're finding key
phrases they know how whether they
whether they went after the Johnny Depp
Amber Heard model but they're finding
those sound bites where they're like
people are going to hashtag this they're
gonna make it Trend they're not gonna
let it fall by the wayside and they're
gonna keep joking and ragging on it and
dragging these people through
because they've made these very as you
said David like digestible Clips in
these these bits so no pun intended on
the digestible and big right exactly
right yeah but I don't know who was on
the team whether it's the producer or
the committee members itself but I think
they're doing a very excellent job at
like taking a very complex yep uh
situation and breaking it out throughout
the days and being like here's the thing
to remember here's the thing right
because you will now never forget these
phrases no for as probably for for you
know the foreseeable future and as soon
as you say it you'll be like oh yeah
right massive jumps they're taking a
team approach and we've heard that from
Jamie Ross in the hall everybody's got
their role right I I want to again say a
genuine heartfelt thank you to Kevin
McCarthy
no [ __ ] dude this is the most bipartisan
investigation probably within the
nation's history to be honest with you
because 911 was pretty non-partisan and
bipartisan but there's still pride and
point to like cover it up right and here
you've got the two Republicans who were
willing to put country over party and
and really go all in on Country over
party and like now we're seeing the best
committee that we've ever seen in terms
of its power from Watergate not since
Watergate which which was you know
people forget it I had forgotten that uh
and I do remember Watergate because I
remember Teapot Dome and I remember the
fall of Rome and all the rest of it but
but all of my contemporaneous memory had
had deprived me of the phrase what did
the president know and when did he know
it that was Howard Baker's phrase we all
remember that or we all know about from
studying it but you know what it was
used for it was used used to give Nixon
cover
Howard Baker asked that question as a
republican partisan he was the the
minority uh he was the chief Republican
on the committee after Senator Irvin the
Democratic chair and he asked the
question because he was hoping the
answer would be the president didn't
know any of this what did the president
know well he didn't know it was all Gene
and it was all of everybody else that
question was meant to exculpate Richard
Nixon and what happened is they
discovered they had tapes right they had
the tapes we knew what the president
knew and we knew it what I what I'm
looking forward to here in this next you
know set of hearings and particularly
when we get into The Tick Tock of the
three hours because that's going to
happen I think toward the end of when
the riots were going on and Trump was
being told to to by Ivanka we're going
to see more of Ivanka there what she
said what she did so in other words the
uh what did the president know and what
he did do about it exactly
what didn't the president do and when
didn't he do it that's right yeah that's
going to be that's going to be the light
Motif I think of the last couple of
these and the last one of course is in
prime time so they're saving the best
for last
um I I don't know there is still some
speculation and I don't think it's uh
it's ruled out whether or not Mike Pence
will wind up making an appearance before
this committee I don't think he will do
you yeah it seemed it seemed pretty um
do you think he will Rachel do you think
Mike no I think he he still is
delusional and thinks that he can be
president
right so I think I think Mark short Mark
short is going to be who we're going to
hear from uh you know what that's the
the Pence word that we're gonna get
around right now I I agree that that's
the plan right now but I I think there
the way they've set this up is is you
know to to Rachel's point he thinks he
can be president he's made three public
speeches where he said Trump was wrong
he didn't want the right to overthrow
the election he's broken with Trump
publicly
Liz Cheney basically teed him up on
Thursday as the man who saved democracy
now it you know this is in the world the
alternate universe we're now in and
which Liz Cheney is a Jedi uh then then
Mike Pence says I don't know where the
the man on the White Horse but if if
that is his
Lane to run for president in as which is
also Liz Cheney's line the anti-trump
then he's got to take his moment in
front of the public to do that right and
isn't this that's not how he's thinking
and and honestly that's just not like
what's happening within the Republican
party so I know people are really
optimistic that this is going to have
some kind of break the Matrix effect on
Republican identifiers and I understand
what your argument is about Watergate
but the problem is is that electorate
does not exist now it's a wholly
different electorate ideologically
recently in many ways so it just doesn't
have the elasticity to do what you're
asking to do what we're looking for is a
movement though there should still be
some movement
because there's part like about half
right-leaning Independence are somewhat
reachable the other half are strident
right but right leaning Independence
there's a part that's reachable and then
you've got Pure Independence and I think
we're going to see uh movement within
those two buckets from this information
especially if it's since it has been
packaged in a way that people who don't
really want to kind of look might
accidentally get exposed to some of
these Revelations which is critical but
I think there's two things that are
going to make the difference right does
the message the Republic the whole thing
was a big con right it was all rigged to
steal your money and there was no big
lie is that gonna get or there was no
fraud right if that is that going to get
hammered into the public psyche through
additional paid media okay and second
off and this is probably more important
honestly but I think both things are
necessary and not sufficient patient
alone the other thing is is the media
going to continue to allow Republicans
to appear on TV all kinds of venues the
newspaper the radio and art and
articulate continue to push the
narrative that the election was stolen
right yeah
Republicans are running around saying
that and so the question comes is CNN
SMBC New York Times Washington Post the
Beltway the White House are they going
to stop letting these [ __ ]
pretend that are they going to cut them
off right away and say we now know
unequivocally that what you're saying is
a [ __ ] lie because if they're not if
they're going to let them continue to go
and do the Stomp and act like it's
normal to be perpetuating a lie that has
been exposed unequivocally it has a lie
then I think we're in big [ __ ]
trouble and I wouldn't expect a lot of
movement I I I think you're spot on
right and I don't think that's going to
happen I mean I'm hearing Chuck odds say
they finally made the case after free
attempts if you get Chuck Todd to please
come here reasonable then you know that
that it is finally moved to that place
where false equivalency is no longer
going to be the norm for the way they're
booking guests and the way they're
treating them I also think that one of
the things that we're going to see when
they name the other members because this
is coming we know this who solicited
Pardons and those members of Congress
are named that's going to be a big
[ __ ] deal I I love that I can say
yeah yeah I I I'm that's all credit to
Joe Biden
speculate on who it is guys who do you
guys think it is come on come on we
already know Matt Gates wanted one yeah
right right well and we see so sorry
well and we see that we included MTG and
bobert though because like keep in mind
those [ __ ] were just getting
sworn in right maybe maybe not maybe not
related include in like
oh guys
I think it's it's uh Jim Jordan I would
yep
uh Mo Brooks right it's it's got to be
the chief of staff right
well I mean look at his text messages
alone the evidence that was on his text
message he's going look oh my God I'm
I'm I'm incriminated just because of
[ __ ] that people are texting me saying
facts about what's going on like they
like it's not like Mark was responding I
mean he was but he was people were just
texting him facts about what was going
on because he's standing next to Trump
he's standing next to him like they're
like I can't get my message through
maybe I'll text the person who I know is
standing right next to him in the room
and I mean you could also say it's uh
you know fist pump not all the way
straight hand out Nazi Josh Hawley right
it could be I I don't I wonder if Holly
and Cruz would would have saw pardons
but we we know that these house members
and many of them went to the White House
apparently the day before the meeting at
the White House that we've been reading
about and hasn't really been detailed as
much and I hope that that's what we're
going to see here I've seen the figure
of 19 members of Congress went to the
White House and that is a very large
number it is that's almost that's almost
the line that would wait for a roller
coaster not a part well that is one of
them because I remember she came out of
the White House and gave an interview
right there yeah we had a great meeting
for stop this feeling it could it could
indeed include her although I think you
know her her court case in Georgia about
qualifying for the ballot seemed to
indicate she's saying she she didn't
know anything and we know she doesn't
know anything therefore she probably
wasn't smart enough to ask for a party
I do think I do think that we're going
to get into double digits
um probably all male members of Congress
absolutely absolutely well here's here's
the other thing
one phrase that I want to put in the
zeitcast because if I can tell it to
Rachel it will get into the Zeitgeist
the pardon boy
and if we start
if that's like the dirty dozen back in
the environmental days the pardon boys
book right now with that David yeah
pardon boys Meme and I will put it on
Republican treason.net for you you can
go Workshop shop to get names that are
fantastically done so that the message
gets across like you can't avoid the
message right
we wait for the name yeah
which is going to happen in the next few
days we're going to know that list of
names because yeah clearly teed that up
it's more than Scott Perry it's going to
be very louder milk a name that no one
knows but yeah tour right so it's it's
the pardon Boys in their tour guide uh
well let me let me tell you on uh to
your point about pardon boys because
I think that's the other thing that
we're gonna see it was just not members
of Congress walking in uh getting
getting pardons for themselves but they
were trying to get whoever would give a
pardon who would that be to say if we
get these people to do these things will
you guarantee them a pardon because
we've already seen we've already seen
the reporting that that had happened so
I don't think they were just going in
and actually I mean they wanted pardons
for themselves of course they wanted to
be protected if this didn't work but
they were trying to make sure that
whoever they coerce to do these acts
would be guaranteed some kind of Pardon
that way that way they could coerce them
to do these things just like the
gentleman and maybe that's why they
played that tape of the gentleman who
was suffering from sucking in the gas he
was saying we didn't really want to do
this but we had to do this and maybe
that's why they played that tape is to
tee up that hey these people these
people not only were lied to by the
president but they might have been lied
to by a member members of Congress and
coerced with with Gardens even I don't
know I mean we need to remember though
that you know we're dealing with uh
Donald Trump who is a a you know a draft
Dodger you know bone spurs so don't be
surprised if let's say that they were
successful in the coup that all those
people wouldn't be the first ones to get
[ __ ] on oh and not get the pardon 100
but the only thing too that David
brought up was you know you said you
were here in 19 and you've got to
remember that even Peter Navarro wrote
in his book that they were a hundred
congressmen that had already
via word committed to uh not certifying
the election so you know I don't I would
guarantee there's an overlap of the 19
within 100 but it could very well be
over 19 too because if that if if well
then again you know Navarro is a bit of
a liar so who knows maybe the number's
exaggerated but uh to know that there
was at least 100 people that were not
going to certify assuming Pence went
through with it
your guys's first show so first night
because there was just no [ __ ] way I
was doing anything but watching that
right that was amazing
but in any case listen we didn't get to
talk about that but like the big
revelation of course is all the footage
of how the Surge and The Siege happens
because it shows you know those
timelines like an hour long and it shows
the proud boys go down there and pound
their way through the soft point of
entry that's going to come from the
ellipse right okay so we now know like
he sent them down and I mentioned that
because we've got this connection with
the proud Boys The Oath Keepers and
potentially potentially because I'm not
a journalist I'm going to say whatever
the [ __ ] I want potentially Roger Stone
and that's where I'm really interested
in here
we refer to him on my show as Dodger
Rhone you know I mean I'll be honest
with you like when like for even months
after it happened I thought no it's most
likely that the [ __ ] that happened at
the Capitol was completely spontaneous
in that the crowd was whipped into a
frenzy and then fed you know I mean but
now we [ __ ] know no no no no it was
planned in advance like Pence's final
decision to certify comes in that
morning too right and like it seems to
me like they had a plan if Pence refuses
Siege
and get him into the car
can I give you a little uh basis of
facts here that we know for sure out in
the public that draw in a guy that might
be named stodger Roan because I think
you're right Rachel because uh Roger
Stone had detail private details
security detail by the proud boys uh
prior to January 5th and there is a they
played the tape on Thursday of Stuart
Rhodes the guy with the eye patch the
founder of The Oath Keepers who who I've
interviewed his son and I'm gonna try to
get Dakota on this week
um to talk about some of the stuff in
the hearing but um I've interviewed his
estranged son and his estranged wife
about Stuart but we seen him and Enrique
tario who we know through last week
Enrique tario was reindited in a
superseding indictment of seditious
conspiracy where Stuart Rhodes is
charged with seditious conspiracy but I
think the most telling facts are that
there was a qrf across the Potomac that
Stuart Rhodes had control over they were
waiting with weapons across the river
for whatever you know whatever might
happen but here's the thing is Brian
Ulrich and Joshua James who have pled
guilty uh in this case and are and are
it seems to be cooperating with Federal
authorities on this seditious conspiracy
case
said Brian Ulrich actually said an open
court to a judge the judge asked were
you in a plot to plan to make sure that
there was no peaceful transfer of power
and Brian Ulrich said to the judge
during that plea hearing yes
um so there was a plan now the most
significant part about that is that
Joshua James and Brian Ulrich were
reassigned to stodger Roan or Roger
Stone as he's Otherwise Known
um to Jan the day of January 6. so again
when I said earlier that they were
texting Mark Meadows because he was
standing next to the president what do
you think Joshua James and Brian
ulrich's job was standing next to Roger
Stone that day when he wasn't at the
Capitol that's right he never left the
hotel room I mean that's right I never
knew that right so like here's the thing
why would you go for this big event at
the White House right if you're Roger
Stone and who who was with him Tony do
you remember it's somebody else that's
pretty major like it was Stone in some
someone else in this hotel room and they
never go to the White House ever it's
right across the street was Bannon there
where was Ben not Bannon it was
definitely a stone in someone else
though like high level and they go and
they sit in this hotel that's across the
street from the White House like
literally right across the street and
they never move they never go to the
event they never go to the to like any
of the reception [ __ ] and you know
you're gonna travel to DC get 10 feet to
the White House and then not go in
that's weird right I mean they have no
one's ever answered that and then as
soon as the siege starts to get out of
control that's when they they book it at
it easy
well that is uh Mike Mike Flynn Owen
Shroyer Roger Stone there were people
that were coming in and out of that I'm
just reading a couple things is it the
Willard war room yeah yeah that was at
the roller Hotel it was Infowars and
Roger Stone both book suites with large
common rooms
yeah exactly who by the way was
obviously he was out and about giving
you know his own little speech right
right he was he was getting his camera
time in Alex right right but there was a
it sounds like there's a ton of people
brown boys and The Oath Keepers combine
this militia line and you can see that I
mean I wish they could just show that
footage again and again I wish that the
January 6 committee was putting up like
all the footage links because it when
you see the organized organized militia
style assault on the Capitol building it
is hard for me not to imagine that
there's not Direction coming for that
well that's the thing we you know we
heard uh there were reports of people
you know communicating back outside with
people having knowledge of different
areas to go into which caused you a
question to be like how did you know
that these you know hallways led to this
or these stairs LED here like how
there's this communication but also the
footage that they showed on Thursday we
some of that stuff we had not seen which
was from the building itself which is
going to be even a bird's eye view
you're talking about the security
cameras yeah right right and you see
what you know what looks like a you know
group of ants storming a hill and you
have it's these people because the only
times that we've ever seen it was from
close up right fighting like a cell
phone or a body yeah I've seen it
actually in a high level bird's eye view
I think was very effective
it's really cut together right yeah
really really effective into your point
Rachel one of the plans as I understand
it is that the report that will be
issued at the end in well not at the end
of the hearings but probably due out in
September is going to not only be a
written report it will be a video report
oh good so we're gonna see this summed
up in ways that people can send it
around and digest they plainly
understand yeah this is different than
the 70s with Watergate that this has to
be done in a way that people get to it
uh over time in their own way I mean in
the way that videos are now posted
Ronald Reagan's video which I think is
now at 400 000. yeah I wanna I wanted to
play that before we left we got about 15
minutes and I don't mean to catch you
David but I I got some breaking news
here um on my watch uh Michael popocket
is has posted Greg Jacobs Pence's
attorney testifies on Thursday there's a
three-page memo he wrote to Pence
telling him any attempt to sir not
certify the election for Biden was he
illegal
um so we'll we'll hear that testimony I
want to show you speaking of The Oath
Keepers
um because we've been helping out these
these we've we've interviewed uh uh
Stuart Rhodes as a strange son a couple
times
um and he actually talks about Rachel
what you're saying and it's called a
military stack when they were go going
into the building to try to take to take
the building and take control of the
building and he talks about that qrf
across the Potomac that that stash of
weapons but Stuart Rhodes is also
there's also um evidence I think Bob
Acosta and and Seth macfarland have
actually uh reported that Stewart Rhodes
was trying to reach Donald Trump by
phone that is key he was trying to reach
Donald Trump by phone which if you think
about it Roger Stone probably has Donald
Trump's phone number I would believe so
I'm just just surmising there but this
is not Don Jr
exactly exactly
um but this is an interview that Gateway
pundit did with Stewart Rhodes from his
jail cell but listen to the end when
Stewart Rhodes says what he says about
Trump I think it's really important uh
what he's helping out these these men
and women who are being prosecuted for
for these made-up crimes as you said
um today there was news
not helping at all and frankly I mean
president Trump I'll give you some props
for saying he may pardon us when he's if
he's re-elected but he needs to step up
and his and his supporters he could
raise money for illegal offense because
he is a co-descendant along with me and
oathkeepers in several civil suits and
he's ultimately a criminal Target as
well
so there you have it even Stewart Rhodes
coming out of his own Mount that of
course he's a co-defendant in some of
these civil suits but saying he's also
he's also a Target in the criminal
investigation
um and again it's hard to believe
anything that Stuart Rhodes would say at
this point but he is he is out of his
own mouth giving giving a public plea to
the president former president United
States Donald Trump saying hey you're
criminally liable and I know it and I'm
telling Gateway pundit this
like he was reminding Trump too that's
right exactly this is total speculation
but it sounded like it was a reminder in
case you forgot the point where you were
saying like look members of Congress
Roger Stone whatever might have had
marching orders to tell people do these
things don't worry the president has
your back we know for a [ __ ] fact the
man does it because he did it down at
the border when he told people to shoot
migrants
bomb Mexico
right here but the the other thing that
is is key about what uh Rhodes said is
we need money
for our Google depends and we just saw
250 million dollars rate did any of it
go to legal fees not a penny for them
if we'll start pissing people off for
our standing trials who are facing this
knowing that money was raised in their
name yep well speaking of legal fees
here's a quick clip of uh some of the
the nut jobs
um and it just this is sort of the clip
from the hearing today I remember that
one of the things Mark said at some
point was you can't show an actual vote
was flipped
which I found at the time to be a
remarkable assertion
because
because you don't have to have the gun
to see the body lying on the floor
bleeding out with five bullet holes in
it was killed by a gun
what they were proposing
I thought was nuts you know the theory
was also completely nuts
[Music]
by the way Justice is our promo code for
10 off on the store dot minusex.com so
go check out uh store.net guys
I mean there's a lot
of like I
there was my main motivation initially
and and I was like what the this is
interesting room Raider what would you
give this you know it comes from get
this it comes from that that kinky uh
fan um romance book gray the gray stuff
oh wow
50 Shades of whatever right s m
is that a cat or a bear
the Bears the panda it's a panda
I don't even know what those silver
things are like I see a Justice LSD man
you know yeah I was like are those
silver hair pieces like what are those
no that's what I was saying it almost
looks like a t-balls and a dick under
them
here's what I believe here's what I'll
tell you here's what I'll tell you think
about this for a second fetterman here
is sitting in front of this backdrop
that he has which we're you know goofing
on here but he's saying what the what
the not the abnormal team abnormal these
like they're [ __ ] nuts they're crazy
nuttier than squirrels well I mean you
got to remember that Lindsay uh Powell
is is saying she's like yeah or yeah uh
I I just like don't even want to
remember what her name is uh but Paul
but she she's also the one you know how
she was like oh we gotta release the
Kraken you know the same day same moment
same hour that rooted Giuliani was just
melting whether that was alcohol or that
was dye or whatever it was
but now she comes out and she's saying
and we knew this beforehand but she's
coming out and saying like oh well I
didn't expect anyone to think that I was
actually saying the truth here like no
one who's reasonable should believe me
it's like right it's very much a Tucker
Carlson approach like no sane person
would ever believe what I was saying on
national TV in defense of voter fraud
right my defense is the stupidity of the
audience right right you have to be so
dumb like right that people would
actually think that right
before because you said something and I
really want to not miss this opportunity
to ask it quickly which is if they're
persuadables in the middle are there no
Republican persuadables I'm seeing about
10 to 15. no you're totally wrong yeah
there is but not chasing these
d-aligning white working class culture
War [ __ ] who can we get where we want
to be we where we want to be tapping
what my strategy is is geared to do not
the messaging but the targeting is to go
into the voter file and identify
potential de-aligning college-educated
especially Republicans and start brand
assaulting them right because like
they're already feeling icky okay and
what what the the way you can think
about this is Democrats like it's not
just that they Republicans started
telling wait what can class men about
these culture [ __ ] and race and sexism
and all that there was a natural like
dealignment happening and then they
enhanced it with intentional material
that broke I mean all of the different
themes tie back to one purpose which is
to break brand loyalty to these
long-time Democrats so that's what
within that one pool where we want to be
hunting and this is not the the pure
independent conversion pool but it
really doesn't matter we want to be we
want to be making it really embarrassing
to still be a Republican and you know
that's really easy to do because the
this party is a total [ __ ] comic show
you know let's talk offline I want to
hear those numbers good sounds great
well here's what I want to tell you
because we've got a few minutes left uh
speaking of
um crazy Republicans we we got a video
uh that Midas Dutch did from Ron Reagan
Jr and not a jersey Republican not a
crazy Republican and actually his dad
President Ronald Reagan would would
probably be uh just rolling in his grave
over some of the nonsense that we've
been seeing coming out of this committee
but I want to play what Ron's response
was to why people should be watching
this week's hearings rather watching
them live or watching Clips or watching
them in in a recorded form so let's
listen to Ron Reagan Jr hi I'm Ron
Reagan Midas Touch has asked me to share
a few Thoughts with you about the
Democracy the ongoing threat to our
Democratic Republic and what we need to
do about that so democracy
as Winston Churchill put it it's the
worst form of government
except for all the others
uh our democracy well it remains a work
in progress and very fragile
as he left the Continental Congress
having helped draft our constitution
Benjamin Franklin was asked well do we
have a monarchy or a republic
a republic he replied
if you can keep it and that's where
things get a little tricky
Franklin and the other Founders
recognized that the gravest threat to
our Republic was internal demagogues and
grifters could uh uh they could they
could gain the system they could delude
a gullible misinformed public seized
power and once they had power
cling to it indefinitely
sound familiar
on January 6 2021 a mob of thuggish
yabos smashed their way into our Capital
assaulted police officers and attempted
to disrupt the certification of Joe
Biden's electoral victory
for the first time in 220 years
there was no peaceful transfer of power
to a few of us here today
this is a Solomon most momentous
occasion
and yet in the history of our nation it
is a commonplace occurrence
the orderly transfer of authority has
called for in the Constitution
routinely takes place as it has for
almost two centuries
and few of us stopped to think how
unique we really are and who was
ultimately responsible for this ugliness
Who lit the fire under that mod why the
sitting president of the United States
Donald Trump that's who
but he had lots of help
only a handful of Republicans offered
any meaningful rebuke
uh the rest of them
supine's spineless Bunch they quickly
fell into line with a huxtron chief
trumpeting his big lie about a stolen
election there's a name for people like
this
Traders don't shy away from it a Trader
is simply someone who betrays these
grasping gutless GOP goons like Jim
Jordan and mo Brooks and Kevin McCarthy
they've betrayed their oath to defend
the Constitution they betrayed their
Nation they betrayed every notion of
decency and they betrayed you by
consistently constantly lying to you and
they think you're too dumb to notice
they need to be held accountable and
that's where the January 6th commission
comes in last Thursday
they began to lay out in clear Stark
compelling detail not just what happened
on January 6th
but the concerted deliberate months-long
plot by Trump and his allies in Congress
and the media to illegally subvert our
democracy and overthrow our duly elected
government
and this is where you come in
your nation needs you to pay attention
Monday Wednesday and Thursday the
commission will continue presenting its
uh its findings tune in as much as you
can if can't watch live you can always
watch the highlights on online or you
know in in replays
um all the major network cable and
broadcasts are covering as well all
except one which is that one is so it
begins with an F it's the um fascist
network uh that's close but not quite uh
phony news I'm getting warmer but um oh
yeah I remember [ __ ] the news let's just
do propaganda
you can tell if you've landed on [ __ ]
the news you'll see a guy named Tucker
Carlson and he's gonna have a face like
this
it's a little like he's struggling with
the concept of conscience or just
wondering where he hid his testicles
don't worry don't bother me you never
had me to begin with
so that's the deal it's simple pay
attention take this seriously re-elect
these trumpist big lie Republicans and
kiss goodbye
honest fair elections and the rule of
law and take it from somebody who's
visited countries without a rule of law
you don't want to live there okay thanks
for your time I'm Ron Reagan still not
afraid of burning in hell but very
worried that our democracy might go up
in Flames oh well I I appreciate that
Ron doing that video and um I I got
about I've got about 30 seconds for you
Rachel and you David give us give us
your take what do you think what do you
think Ron Reagan would ask his dad
President Ronald Reagan in this moment
what do you think he'd be asking him and
what do you think Ronald Reagan would
say
Ronald Reagan would [ __ ] burn these
[ __ ] down dude he was no
traitor okay and and Junior there is
dead on [ __ ] right we gotta call it
what it is it's treason it's being a
traitor do that at Republican
treason.net
all right thank you just a a fact check
he's not Junior they have a different
middle name
but what he would say to his father is
uh I wish you were here yes if he were
he would take them on just as John
McCain did all right he would not
tolerate this
I I appreciate both of you coming thank
you very much um you guys should join us
in the rest of the week again we're
gonna have coverage here on the Midas
media Network
um everyone knows Wednesday and Thursday
we have more hearings at the same exact
time hopefully we won't have a delay
with Witnesses but we will start at the
exact same time
um nine nine a.m Eastern uh for those
hearings so please you two are welcome
to join us and everyone else join us for
that coverage on the Midas media Network
don't forget to download these podcasts
uh the Midas touch podcast I believe
they're going to put the all these up on
the directories as well Apple's Spotify
and Google and go go also subscribe to
our YouTube channel the Tony Michaels
podcast if you've enjoyed our production
of the broadcast here don't forget don't
forget just like the bat says justice is
your promo code for 10 off all the merch
at store dot Midas touch.com so visit us
there
um and then when you think of massive
dumps think of Gabe Sanchez that's right
thanks for joining us thanks for joining
us everyone
um we again we will be broadcasting on
Wednesday uh and please subscribe to my
dis Touch YouTube channel our YouTube
channel do not miss the Wednesday
broadcast or the Thursday they will
always be on repeat and replay there uh
thank you for joining us for our
coverage of the January 6th uh select
hearings uh this is day two of the live
hearing coverage thanks for joining us
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign